Thomas Aquinas I put quite a few things
on the board excuse me because there's a
few preliminary things I want to get out
of the way before we look at today's
stuff one of them is last class I hinted
at this but I didn't actually go into it
I said that one of the things that you
want to keep in mind with Thomas is the
structure of the text right so you guys
have now read several different
questions of Thomas Aquinas you know
that they begin with an article and so
the structure of the Summa Theologica
this big giant word actually if you buy
copies of it you know big thick text
it's supposed to cover all these
different things that a theologian the
second part the second part first part
of the second part has to do with the
nature of human beings first part about
God we're not reading that because this
isn't an intro to philosophy class or
philosophy religion class so we're not
interested in whether you can prove God
exists or anything yeah we're interested
in the upshot for human beings Thomas
Aquinas the way that he works at things
is dialectical and when you're working
at things dialectically one of the
things that you do is you look at what
other people have
and the reason they do this is because
probably you're not the only person in
the world who's ever thought of
something and it's a good idea before
you actually you know open your mouth
and give your opinion on something to
see what other intelligent people have
had to say about you get to do this with
research papers you guys all remember
writing a paper and you didn't have any
sources you can turn it in and your
professor said this is all nice but I
would like to see you engage with some
other thinkers does that ring a bell
well Thomas this is the way he does
things so it'll start out with a
question like for instance the question
that we're going to start with today is
this is kind of a technical one whether
it's seen as fitting fittingly defined
as a word to eat or designer country to
the eternal one that's a question is it
this way or is it that way that you can
answer it with a yes or a no in art
Marist colors red and white
that's a yes/no question two right
answers yes our Catholic Memorial and
Waukesha's colors purple and white
that's no question blue and gold
right did the Packers win yesterday yes
or no question they did so you start
with a question and this is the way a
lot of philosophy works philosophers
don't begin by saying okay I know
everything and here's how it goes they
open questions and so Thomas is doing
that and with a question you could say
yeah sure you can say no so let's say
Thomas already has some idea he wants to
say yes does that mean that he should
look at everybody else who said yes
first
very good you should look at how other
people are approaching the topic we
don't agree with yeah so you can see how
to make your very good because your your
own argument is stronger not just by
getting a whole bunch of people on your
side but by showing that other people
who are reasonable human beings we have
something on the ball who aren't just
sounding off because they like to talk
or something like that have something
real to say about this if they have
something valid to say then you've got
to find some way to address that so
that's what he does with these
objections he frames some arguments
against his own position and sometimes
they're good arguments sometimes they're
bad or if they're good arguments you
know people do these people say well
this is not a bad argument it's wrong in
this respect but it's also right in this
respect if it's a bad argument it's
usually a bad argument that he heard
coming from somebody else they'll say
well this isn't a good argument here's
why then they have another thing where
you give somebody who's actually on his
side but goes too far who say maybe just
resolves the issue by saying well
Augustine said and you know if you're
trying to convince another person about
some some point rationally is it enough
for you just to say that Thomas Aquinas
Aristotle said what do you
you have to be able to apply your own
applause the situation let's go that's a
good way yeah and no you don't
necessarily have to be original in order
to be to be right with you
but you're correct if you're just taking
somebody else's ideas and you're
regurgitating them you're not actually
showing that you thought about beer your
song yeah doesn't say you can save
Aristotle said this doesn't mess with ya
if we consider the present time and what
the person you're talking to
trying to convince is like what their
perspective is who couldn't play it -
their perspective then yeah kind of
understanding that's there's actually
two good points in here and then
actually those actually sort of continue
mr. Varon Hollis's climate I was
thinking one is you're right
Aristotle died back in the third or the
fourth century BC
after itself because he had to leave the
Athens because there were riots then
again it's foreigners like himself after
Alexander that Thomas Aquinas is 13th
century that's a long time ago there's
lots of things that Thomas Aquinas
didn't write about didn't think about
because they didn't exist way society
was very different if you read Aristotle
Thomas Aquinas you will say especially
women in the class you will see him
saying sort of dismissive things about
women and being involved in philosophy
then if you were able to sit Aristotle
and Thomas down right now the philosophy
class or gonna take them to the bar
drinks they probably would recant them
because they look at that society and
they would have to apply it in different
ways so that's one important point you
have to be able to adapt whatever it is
that you're thinking about to the
contemporary situation and then you have
to be able to reach out to other people
who don't share your own point view from
that mr. journalist by saying you're
just regurgitating somebody else you're
not actually showing that you thought
about it if you're just saying well
so-and-so thinks that so therefore you
should think it that's not a very
persuasive way of reaching somebody
else's we're gonna censor the
an expert perennial and unity have I the
- yes - Aristotle the wonder why there's
Valerie that's another very good point
why should we care
you're right first of all there on any
given issue you can find tons of extras
now with the internet it's really easy
to choose type in something like a
controversial issue not abortion
necessarily a lot of them didn't think
about that punishment you'll find
philosophers on this side and
philosophers on that side and if you're
like at a debate team that's all you do
is you pile up well so and so so this so
and so so this highly up authorities but
you're right why should we care about
what the aerosol things instead of what
Oprah things people according over a
long whether they are sloth actually our
society won't they she's not actually
here that was but she certainly has a
big following doesn't work you know you
pick any other configure why should we
care about what they think well again
this goes back to the same point unless
you've actually grappled with the
thought yourself and can explain to
somebody else why that position is
worthwhile you're just throwing out you
know here's a physician here's an
authority to back it up and you can do
the same thing with any text you like
you could say well my textbook in health
class and this you can say my my
critical thinking
says this it doesn't mean it's right
so what we want to do is we want to
think about this reasoning through we
want to look at the arguments both for
and again that's what's going on in the
first part of every article in the
condensed text that I have created for
you I don't include that stuff because
that's not actually promises on plots
that's sort of getting ready then Thomas
gives you his own thoughts at the point
where he says I respond that or I answer
that there's different ways of
translating and we call this the
responsive and traditional studies when
he says I answer that
that's where Thomas is actually giving
you his own position it's not until then
he's you know he's laying the cards on
the table he's not flipping anything
over until he gets there and then he'll
reply to the objections because he
thinks that it's important if other
people have arguments against your
position like you said you maybe make
your own paper stronger you make your
own position stronger by showing them to
can actually respond to those not just
brush them away not just hide them that
doesn't resolve an issue and the issues
that he's trying to deal with they're
pretty big stuff so before we're going
to the big stuff the sort of you know
crux of the issue I do want to put in
one other thing so today we're looking
at somewhat a long ago by the way you
could say some of TI lo VI or so much ll
become either one is both of them are
actually used that both of them are used
by Thomas dollars I got to fight with a
guy in graduate school this is stupid
but I gotta [ __ ] fight with this guy
at school and both of us came from other
schools where I think I was saying it's
somewhat a low-key cup because the only
copies that seeing where no no it's
somewhat a low GI because many copies
you'd ever see with that then one's a
library just found out don't you can
plant both of these if they both mean
the same thing the continuum of theology
we're looking at question 55 question 55
has to do with virtue we're very
interested in that topic break right now
if you go on and you read question 56
and there's no reason why you have to
stop jumping up just where we're
stopping with the class session if you
think read that you will learn a lot
more about what Thomas and what
Aristotle virtue that may not be a
sufficient draw question 71 has to do
with life and if you go on to question
72 you know how have you all heard about
the seven deadly sins yeah well what are
they can anybody rattle monka
degrees right okay very good
it's not in question 71 it's in question
of 72 that he will talk about
and deadly sense and the reason he talks
about that this is actually a little bit
worth reflecting why are they called
eminent sense is it because if you do
them that's gonna get you that's not the
reason why you're greedy no you're not
gonna start you're gonna die but it's
gonna kill your character and how other
people what's you good yeah that's a
good metaphorical wind you'll kill your
character you're right they will it'll
lead to an are the word appear yet
devices yeah that's what they're also
they by themselves can lead to your
downfall you're right
do you know why they're called cardinal
vices the sort of beginning vices
because they lead so many other words if
you're greedy remember we looked at this
earlier with Aristotle we with us we
talked about people who are greedy they
will do all sorts of things to satisfy
that greed if you're in law school you
will do all sorts of things to satisfy
that if you're slothful if you just like
to lay around all day you know you will
not do a whole bunch of other things
that interfere with that
so again if you're interested in that
thomas pots about that much more in
question
72 we're going to look at 71 because
we're looking at just a general stuff
that's that's worth keeping in mind so
we're starting with the last question
today the park Gazette that helps us put
all this in perspective this connects
what we did last class with what we're
going to do next
so Thomas references a couple things
when we talked last class about the
divine command theory of ethics the
natural law theory of ethics and he's
you throwing the wrong language that
looks a lot like the divine command
theory things are good because God said
that they're good things are bad because
God said it so let's take adultery Yeah
right
God doesn't like adultery how do we know
that Bible tells us that the Bible you
know if we don't read the Bible
religious leaders will presumably will
tell us that God cheat on your husband
sleep with your neighbors wait for us
right with the divine command theory one
of the problems with it is let's say God
changed his mind tomorrow said she'll
commit adultery well then according to
the divine command Theory the adultery
would not only be a good thing
it could be required more committing
adultery they had a personal so let's
put that let's put that aside that's not
going to be a very helpful way of
looking at epics the natural law theory
there's a couple things in all of them
one is God isn't going to change the
mind why because God is rational and if
you're rational you come back to the
same things over and over again once
you've actually fought them out and
figured that loud if you're actually
figuring things up correctly you're not
going to be the angel you know I'm
putting aside things like self-defense
and you know protecting the innocent
it's like that how many of you like
changed your mind about whether it's
okay to kill people nobody do you
foresee herself at some point in time
you know really looking at the issue
whether you should kill people and
saying to yourself you know I used to
think that it was rational not to kill
people but now I see that I was not
correct back that the rational thing to
do is really to kill people none of you
foresee that that happened that's good
because if you did it's always going to
be wrong to kill P and if some people
happen to think it's okay because you
know there's something wrong with their
reason there's no mention to using it
whether they're allowing their passions
to interfere that where they've got
certain vices that doesn't actually
change the fact that it's wrong just and
if you're rational you'll realize that
and Thomas talks about there being two
rules for the human will what's the
what's the will that's not a term you've
used a lot this this semester because
Plato is actually
so by the time the Thomas is around
we've been arguing together your will is
your capacity to choose right
every single one of you is in this
classroom because you chose to be here
get out of robot right robot side we
don't know unless we don't when you go
off it that sort of thing that's kind of
science fiction let's let's just assume
another video robots right you all see
in science fiction movies where there
are robots that look like human beings
but but there's something wrong with
them right they don't have a free will
robot actually you know that the word
means comes from check and enslaved
robot is a slave to its program none of
your robots you chose to come here
you came here of your own free will why
did you tell we've talked about this
before
why are you here of course they have it
could be a reason
how many just rolled out of bed put on
some clothes got yourself over here and
didn't give it a moment's life
yeah I'm willing to bet there's more
people than one that that was the case
poor feiiow happens to meet someone even
though there's a lot of things that
takes me to it to get here let's be
honest about that we are creatures of
habit
how many of you waiver and said it's a
cold outside you know and it's a nice
morning to sleep bit how many of you
said
last one for only one person yeah I'm
willing to bet that that's the case you
know what happened there you you made a
freewheel decision you had two
alternatives stay in bed be comfortable
or come to class be less comfortable but
learn things you chose you are
responsible for them you're not you're
not only responsible for bad things that
that you happen to do from time to time
you're responsible for the good things
because you have a will now what should
regulate our wills if we don't choose to
regulate our wells that we will choose
all sorts of things but we'll probably
choose badly well what should regulate
it are two different rules and one of
those rules from is an honest reason our
capacity to think things out does that
mean that you know you just sort of get
into a situation with draw out your what
should I do that our works don't you do
that
sometimes I mean I think wouldn't not
first and it's a problem that you
haven't had before you might do it but
let's like think it's more of a habit
like that you just react
yeah yeah and a lot of times what you're
doing you know Aristotle or Thomas would
say you have the principal in you and
you sort of draw conclusions from it
like you you see somebody out there I'm
willing to bet all of you are young
people you see somebody out there 9w and
they're trying to cross the street and
the light is gonna change and let's say
it's a young kid think about five yeah
and they're going through the crosswalk
what would you do
stop them in the middle of the street
stare out the middle of the street I
don't think any of you really have to
think that much about this what would
you do know if you heard if you're
you're at the cross fashion blend stuff
so here's 9w busy highway and people
drive fast down there and they don't
always stop at the lights and you're at
the crosswalk about to cross over to the
other side and there's a little kid
right in the middle you're looking at
the lights and you see the lights are
about to change
yeah you would probably run out there
grab the kid and rather the other side
right how many of you would do that yeah
now in doing that you would actually
some of you would like think for a
minute
holy crap what should I do and then you
would lay out some alternatives a shower
should I run but most of you would
almost instinctively do it you don't
realize that there is a reasoning
process going down at the time you're
actually drawing on your capacities as a
human being to see what the city
requires to think to the yeah when you
have two different alternatives and we
have a real genuine world alone and it
seems like well if you do this
somebody's going to get hurt but if you
do this somebody's going to get hurt or
this one level that seems to be the
right thing but on another level this
seems to be the right time you start
thinking about this what are you doing
is your reasoning I think quite often we
make use techniques right you might sit
down did you guys know that it lets you
know that e-list is sometimes a Ellison
crowing time this lets you just draw tea
and you you know you're trying to figure
out should you do this or not
and your write down what the good parts
are and what the bad parts are if you're
doing that you are reasonable that's
practical rationality everyone what
about when you talk with somebody like
like your frat
somebody that we look up to a mentor and
you're trying to figure out what you
want to do
that's reasoning to actually figuring
out that you ought to ask another person
to help you out and thinking these
things out that's a smart thing a lot of
people get themselves in trouble because
they don't want to ask anybody they
don't want to lay the problem that they
have out before new if you put several
people together you may come up with a
more rational solution now we're not
perfect right so this isn't always going
to give us the rights of the solution in
every situation but it's not because
there's something wrong with season
itself it's because we're not fully
rational you know if you you get me very
bad because I'm a problem with other
person that's as problems long-standing
problems with with anger I become less
rational I start to think that some
things are okay which are no kidding
right
if you struggle with loss or pride or
read or something like that then you
have a weakness in that respect and that
can sort of short-circuit reason so the
really greedy person on some level they
know they shouldn't take the you know
all the cake but they tell them
something it's okay
raise it which reason will tell them no
no you shouldn't do that we should leave
enough for other people so there's
there's human reason and how do we how
does it work for us well Thomas says
virtues these sort of habitual ways of
behaving and feeling that we developed
over time then if you do if you develop
a virtue you will start to become more
like the person who runs out and grabs
the kid but that's like the person who
has to think about things in each case
because eventually it will become second
nature to do the right thing to reach
the right rational conclusions and if
you do it often you can cultivate this
and then there's the natural law and the
natural log we're going to look at it
next class the natural law fires from
principles that Thomas thinks are based
is the way that remains our basic
inclinations and if we think them out we
follow them through we will arrive at
the right thing to do but she says
there's another rule that's given to us
as well God juries would be the eternal
why is it the eternal law because you
know presumably God exist for eternity
and so if he made some sort of rule did
you just one day say if human beings are
screwing it up I'd better make some
rules now he would have thought these
things from all eternity what I could
talk much about this today and we're
actually not going to talk this much
about this next place except insofar as
it ties in with the natural law the
natural law Thomas Texas
we'll get to that next class what we're
going to look at today is more in terms
of virtues whatever virtues and and
water crisis so let's look at what you
know about virtually is so far no sense
first of all what are some virtues that
you can even name we've been talking
about this now for a couple weeks
yeah patience okay what is the patient's
not getting upset with people when they
you know expect you to wait around them
and who are they to make any way around
it patients actually I still think what
Aristotle talked about through the
translation
yeah
we don't want our society moderation
very good what else yeah just as one of
the most important virtues the one that
actually brings all of us together
Aristotle says err something like she
says something interesting he says that
justice is one of the virtues but all
the virtues can actually be thought of
in terms of justice as what we hold to
other people in our temper or being
generous any other virtues you can think
of that's a goodness the word there were
some of some others that we've you know
Thomas talks about all of these he also
adds some theological riches to them and
if you remember in reality like cata
chemical training you know a Bible
school or stuff like that and there's my
faith hope and charity sometimes you
know very devout people like to name
their daughters vehicle for charity
they're naming them after virtues faith
hope and charity are also those sorts of
things where I could talk that much
about that in this class but
a biology class those are some of the
virtues Thomas is actually going to talk
in terms of not only the carpet of Isis
but the cardinal virtues the ones that
so what are these all have in common
what makes them virtues we've got a list
of issues what can you say them what
makes them yeah okay so they are why are
they seemed almost common sensible there
go ahead and say because they
they awesome right I mean people think
something they're gonna die with and
some people are mistaken like they think
that drag racing is courage right drag
race was full harness
to kill people unnecessarily but we
consider these to be good because they
actually are types of witness ok very
good
I mean between two extremes how do you
actually figure out what the mean is
sometimes you feel that but what else do
you have
you look at they're just people models
they also use reason okay
you have to figure out like for example
I'll take myself myself mr. Bansi so
that's actually my way closer to 60 mr.
Ramsey and I should probably eat about
the same amount of food right maybe he
should actually reward because he's
younger he's still his body still
filming plus he's doing athletics so he
needs both of us probably and willing
that that should probably eat one and a
half to two times as much as say mr.
Walter or miss Bryer right how do we
figure that out we didn't just say well
everybody should have the same amount
right in the middle not too much a
little see thought that up didn't lesser
what did one of the relevant facts in
the case you know there's sure Walter
probably weighs you know less than than
two-thirds maybe even just a half
tarantulas so she wouldn't need half as
much food right you'd need half as many
calories half as much protein that's
reasoning trying to figure out whether
you're being greedy or desiring things
to the right amount that's using reason
and like I you know like I said before
you could do this sort of just
instinctually you figure it out yourself
it becomes a matter of habit
right or you might ask somebody if I
wanted to figure out what the right
amount of food for me is who should I
consult nutritionist nutritionist or a
dietitian thank you say you know main
reason I don't is because I like to use
as much as I want not being mothered
that's more than I actually need
what about saving we get angry you know
when we get angry we are really
unreliable judges of whether were in the
right to be what's the best thing to do
you ask somebody else do you think I'm
actually in the right to be this angry
about this thing what do they usually
telling what you were doing that is you
were using released and if you do that
often enough it will become they happen
and what kind of habit is it it becomes
with Thomas calls and question fit the
quick question 55 article 3 and
operative happen which means that it's
not just consider good it's not just a
type of goodness it is productive of
goodness the reason why we think that
virtue is good is because a person who
he has a virtue will do good things it's
not just a thing are good they do good
things and they do them habitually if
they do them every once in a while we
say they're not but yet virtuous that
may be on the right track maybe they're
they're trying to you know you gotta
think about anger how many of you lost
his temper say the last week
none of you lost your temper in the last
week serious only one person hard to
believe two teens plus if you if you get
yourself into situations and keep on
exercising these sorts of things you
will start doing the right thing I don't
make no distinction no reason to the
right thing because reason the hand here
and your desires and your habits we'll
all come together they won't be at war
with each other
angers are particularly bad for that
because what does anger do almost
immediately shucks
or subversive to the so Thomas calls
these operative campus a they produce
good thing they says virtue implies a
perfection of power perfection of power
bands
this is realizing what it is for you to
be a comedian
think about sort of a model of a good
human being and who do you guys consider
to be good food people people have made
almost so don't say grandma we don't
know your Uncle Joe who do you consider
me a good human being for models for you
it's a god-given okay so what was good
about this guy he wasn't big and strong
and that's that's pretty clear
use a lot of reason yeah he wrote a lot
talked a lot
what did he use reason to do he didn't
use it to rob banks to create peace ok
so Gandhi was a peaceable man he
actually found ways to use conflict this
is a genius to use conflict to create
the opposite conflict to create peace
and not just like peace work we always
turn our backs on each other
our separate ways he wanted to go beyond
that sort of Martin Luther King
resistance or student of Gandhi by
getting us to respect among each other
that's pretty good
what that's doing if you follow somebody
like Gandhi you're saying which are you
so or any of these other people that we
look up to you are what Thomas had said
perfecting the human nature human nature
is not something good right off the bat
by itself it takes work because we have
tendencies to go wrong on when it comes
to this there so we do tend to be greedy
rather than being just don't we're
tempted to do that we are tempted to
take more pleasure when we're faced with
situations demanding currently we do
often tend to feel a lot of fear and
sometimes we did that going to perfect
human nature which is what virtues do
means to realize even nature to make
yourself in some way more fully what a
human being ought to be and it also
makes it more free we can think about
the courage is a great example if you
have courage you get into tough
situations
you know they don't end up taking
control of your life do that County is a
good example
takes a lot of courage to stand up I'm
aware of people who would like to have
an excuse to kill you and say you should
not do that
that takes a lot of guts now let's look
at one of the other depression he says
how do we define virtue
these are all your right these are all
parts of virtue and I'm glad that you
guys could come up with a lot of these
that shows that you're thinking about
this think this is sort of sticking
Thomas says the end of virtue is this
production is its operation if you have
a virtue what a virtue produces our good
things on the other hand if you have a
virus what is the price for bad things
but not to pay things let's talk that
this is perfectly white but they had
human actions so if your dream being 3d
by itself is just a state and we
consider being greedy bad right why is
being greedy bad well because it's a
habit that produces greedy actions what
are what are the sort of actions of the
greedy person takes right yeah people
often steal because of
they want to have more than they ought
to have brother things that people might
do have agreed yeah why yeah that's true
that's true that they go like well yeah
they they may become misers they don't
contribute to the public good
people kill off you don't necessarily
just be a killer for hire good example
the personal kills for money there's
people that kill other people just
because they interfere with the name
comes true that's being productive of
particularly bad things now how do we
know what is virtuous or talk about the
reason it gives us thanks
let's look now yeah vices talked about
virtues
realizing our future I don't know how
you get it picked up on this Thomas Fox
about three different things
da opposed to Bernie and being the post
in different ways and there is some
theological language here and so if the
notion of sin really bothers you or
something like that you can substitute
it and you know a bad act or something
like that
yeah and he starts asking whether vices
country to virtue and some of the people
say well no it's not vice that's
contrary virtue because what do we say
is actually a contrary to virtue so now
what what is the sin when people use
that that term what are they within that
tradition you know okay then that's
that's we've got the broad category of
evil
what else that yes so it's a different
than saying advice advice is and they
don't feel well
God doesn't like something like that you
could drop that out of the picture
picture you get a same too sad an evil
deed and then what is malice now this is
just sort of badness analysis is a
broader Kenneth confine it can virtue be
it posed only two to one of these you
know sometimes things have more than one
opposite don't this it depends on the
point of view they like let's say we're
talking about college students how many
New York are seniors yeah quite a few
what's the opposite of a senior a
freshman sure because if seniors is
ending the process and a freshman is
beginning the process that's a trick
question
because that is correct as the freshman
is opposed to a senior a certain way
what some guy on the street who has
never been to college at all aren't they
in some other way more opposed to a
college senior somebody who's about to
graduate from college they are but it's
in a different way isn't so it's the
same thing with virtue Thomas virtue is
productive
virtuous acts that is opposed by sin
right virtue is also the opposite of
vice and virtue is the goodness that
human beings ought to have this other
case of goodness too right being in
shape that's a good thing but what's
really distinctive about us as human
beings we were students Thomason Arizona
is an degrees and as rational creatures
what really makes us good what is our
goodness in esteem virtues that's to
realize what it is for us to be human
beings and these are all you know
interconnected and sorry the design that
again we would come back to you know
when I brought the seven deadly sins
they're also called the capital of Isis
why do they call the capital of Isis
Greta's is not Grivas estates is not
really a synonym as such it's a it's a
vice but it's productive of a bad action
system just like generosity or justice
yeah as such is not a good act but it's
a state which is productive
since the main issue of the with what he
says that you know virtue isn't
necessarily the opposite of virtue isn't
necessarily a sin like you will get
perfectionist
yes you know being a perfectionist isn't
necessarily a bad evil thing but still
not be virtuous to yourself because
you're going overboard with what you
have to do you might be moderate with it
you have to do but yeah let's let's
refrain that being perfectionist is not
bad
states like being greedy those being
greedy as a lot easier to see as a bad
because you know things that clearly bad
actions being a perfectionist we're a
little bit more insidious is still bad
actions
insofar because they actually can be bad
to us an action can be nice or
positively bad it does harm to somebody
you can you can you can tell just
looking at it it's a bad thing
it can also be bad because it blocks our
development or it keeps us from doing
what we want to be doing that would be a
good thing to do
it takes away it good so there's like
positive badness and then there's like
all primitive and it strikes me that
being a perfectionist is more of it
involves pruvit of badness so if I'm a
professional so actually I do
taxes so sometimes I don't get things
done that I should get done maybe some
of you can relate to this why not
because spent too much time on one of
them yeah well you know everything if
you're a perfectionist
not just the whole thing you're working
on but every single piece has to be
perfect
right it's a lot about a fence and you
can spend so much time on one piece that
you don't get to the other pieces never
have that happened to you paper
something else you were working on now
you're right it's not a sin like you
know God is going to strike you dead for
not having finished your paper but it's
it's not a good thing and it's it's
taking away is blocking the road to some
good thing so it's bad in a different
sense that possibly pretty small I think
on the scale set it up against greed
blot me lost those sorts of things it
looks pretty young pretty innocent that
but it could be a good leader problem to
think about perfectionist parent who
isn't there for their kid the way they
ought to be because they're so obsessed
with their own stuff and getting it just
right that they're not providing a kid
nurturing or
then you might see something more than
it might turn into actual positive harm
now he he says a few other interesting
things about Vice this is where we're
going to spaces visited in article 2 so
as stated above Isis contrary to virtue
now the virtue of a thing what is what
is the virtue of that unity is
consistent being well disposed in a
manner befitting its nature so you know
the virtue of a de log is to be healthy
and mark the way it's supposed to in a
play and that's what was done so you can
talk about virtue that's that's not the
moral virtue
okay the virtue I suppose you could even
talk about like you know the virtue of
my phone is when everything is working
the right way all the gaps are updated
the operating system is the latest so
that they can function the way it's
supposed to function well what about
human beings what are what are our
functions were more complicated we have
all these things with respect to our own
actions as we're free agents and I'm
freedom we can use as well or we can
screw things up and it's not just how I
affect myself I'm connected to all of
you to write survive if I've got vicious
habits I'm not going to just be a
viciously towards myself I'm gonna be a
vicious me towards you know all right
fine yeah I think if I have vicious
disposition with respect to anger that
only on it and maybe provoked your
viciousness disposition
not least because I'm actually a mama
right so the the vice of anything
consists of being disposed in a manner
not befitting its nature so here's what
you have to think about how should a
human being need this is what reason
want to be telling us is it better to
the most Inger is it better to lose your
temper easily and hold grudges or is it
better to only lose your temper when
somebody really is back to hold onto
grudges but be willing if the person is
gonna admit that they did something
wrong which is better the second right
and the reason we can tell you that and
why is that better for is it just better
by itself you need to have a habit of it
means that a positive outcome well right
why is it better to be forgiving and not
to be a gradual I mean if you look at it
though if you're forgiving you forgive
everybody that would be a bus that would
be advice but if you haven't balance
then it would because you give everybody
like a just chance you know you're not
just you don't shut in the mouth for a
mistake that you've made or social yeah
you can preserve relationships and one
of the things about us human beings is
we are we are creatures that exist
through our relationships so if I'm
going Raja's all the time I'm kinda gave
up who do we get in conflict with to do
we get in conflicts with perfect
strangers out there on the street if you
are you've got some real anger problems
right but who do we tend to get into
let's hear that are close with friends
family yeah and that's why anger and
woman grudges is so harmful because if I
you know if I hold grudges against all
the people in my family because
everybody my family MERS will sooner or
later take me alive everybody is your
right you'll probably take them on if
we're all holding grudges against each
other and we're not giving each other
second chances we're gonna destroy our
relationships we're going to be very
unhappy we're not going to be able to
work together we're not gonna be able to
learn from each other we're not going to
be able to realize nature the way it's
supposed to you realize if we're willing
to forgive each other not not for
everything like mr. Bennett Gucci points
out if you're forgiving everything there
there's a problem too but if you're
forgiving when you want to be forgiven
that allows relationships to continue
and it's even approximately how many of
you had to forgive a friend to ask Rudy
over but we didn't cut them out of your
life and you're closer now because even
what you did there is you realized the
potential of human nature you learn
something in the process you learn
something about what it means to be
human you may not have actually been
able to see that ahead of time before
you started to engage in the process of
reconciliation of the person it's the
same way with every one of the other
virtues if we cultivate them they help
us to live a more human life so being
courageous prevail the coward lives a
less human life than the person who has
courage they back out a lot of things
that this should they pass up
opportunities
the person who is on the other extreme
one is rapt who jumps into things far
too easily that they a lot I mean I'll
stay away from their cutting themselves
off Thanks
what about generosity if you're if
you're stingy what's your life like
compared to somebody was generous see
these virtues and these vices they're
not just things that we just happen is
human needs to think are good that you
know our society tells us they're good
and therefore you know kind of like in
addition they actually aren't good
they're hard to see sometimes until you
actually get in them and see how a life
looks when it has a virtue or when it
has a flex this is why watching movies
and reading books and novels and
thinking about stories your stories is
so useful the stories of those who use
content older adults manage to screw up
their lives and then get their lives
back on the right track when they did
that most likely what they did is they
acquired some vices those vices screwed
up their lives forget up their
relationships screwed up their
themselves as human beings somebody came
along and said hey knock it off this is
the way you should act and they showed
them some virtues and then they begin
that long hard process of changing the
habits and eventually coming to be the
person that you know that yes so that's
that's something to think about
over the next week or so the last bit of
promise that were to look
is the biggest pictures what is the
natural law the natural law is going to
be what what helps us to cultivate
virtues but it's also going to give us
some principles so I'll see you all next
week